okay
hi everyone back again for another
episode of science and technology q a
for kids and others um
i might say that i am thinking about
doing uh
some of these on different topics
including some about history
and so on and if people are interested
in that let us know
and i'd be happy to try and answer
questions about
kind of things i know about the history
of science and technology both from
experiences i've had and
from the things i've studied but that's
a different topic
okay we have a few questions that were
left over from last time
uh there's one here from lolite
do i think that neurons work more as
mechanical systems
or on the quantum level is the
computational power done by neural net
or more by by the neurons themselves or
more by microtubules
okay let's see what i can do with that
so okay so what we're talking about here
is kind of how do brains work and what
matters
in the way that brains work so what's
in our brains well there's a lot of
nerve cells uh there's maybe a hundred
million nerve cells
um in our brains and and the nerve cells
are these things which have
kind of a body and they have long
spindly arms
that look kind of a little bit like
wires and sometimes nerve cells will
have a thousand
of these spindly arms maybe even ten
thousand of these
and these sort of spindly arms reach out
uh across
to lots of other neurons so there's this
big network of neurons in our brains
that uh is is the way that we process
information
now how does this actually work well
there are electrical signals
generated by these neurons and what
happens is neuron is like a little tiny
electric battery
it's a little tiny electrochemical
system that
is basically generating uh pulses of
electricity
and um the uh the way what's happening
is when when a
roughly when a nerve cell gets to the
point where it's been
excited enough by other nerve cells that
it
is touching then it will produce a pulse
of electricity
which it then sends to other nerve cells
that it's touching
and that's that's roughly how the sort
of the the basic idea of how neurons
work
now neurons have they have on these
little sort of spindly arms
they have what are called dendrites and
what are called axons
the axons are the places where um the
the nerve cell is kind of sending out
pulses of electricity the dendrites the
places where it's receiving them
and in general there are what are called
synapses which are the junctions between
nerve cells where these where arms from
different nerve cells
match up and at those synapses the
actual way that the sort of pulses of
electricity are sent through
are through these molecules called
neurotransmitters of which there are
several things like acetylcholine
serotonin dopamine um they each
uh these neurotransmitters have slightly
different chemical characteristics
slightly different kinds of cells that
sort of specialize in producing that
neurotransmitter and slightly different
effects when you
if you you know take all kinds of weird
drugs and things they'll have all kinds
of effects on different
um uh different levels of these
neurotransmitters in your brain
and also different diseases have effects
on on populations of
of nerve cells that are associated with
particular neurotransmitters and so on
but so so the basic idea is
nerves in our brains all the time they
are
basically firing in the sense that
they're producing these puzzles of
electricity that they send to other
nerve cells and so on
and this happens roughly a thousand
times a second roughly
um and and if you you can record
electrically from even a single nerve
cell
um in some organisms it's pretty easy
um like the the squid has the giant axon
which is a particularly big nerve which
makes it particularly easy to record
from but it's possible to record from
from nerve cells and lots of organisms
um
and uh in humans it's well it's more
difficult because
we don't tend to have uh there's all
kinds of questions about how we might do
it in humans
you can do a certain amount of uh when
you if you put the electrical
connections you know on your
on your scalp you can record eeg
but that's a very mushed out version of
uh
of of the electrical activity of your
brain you can you can
detect at the micro volt level you can
detect
some electrical activity but what you're
detecting by just having 12 electrodes
on your head
or something is the collective effect of
billions of neurons
um not the individual kind of more uh
information processing effects of
individual neurons
but in any case you know so if you
record from a single neuron
you will find usually that the thing is
kind of quiescent it's not making any
you know you've turned the electrical
signal into a sound it'll be like quite
quiescent and then
suddenly it'll wake up and it'll have a
whole burst of
you know kind of um uh
uh bursts where it produces a spike
train
of lots of pulses of electricity
generated by the nerve cell
a thousand times a second and then maybe
it'll go quiet again for a while and
start up again and if you kind of record
those things it's like
what's actually going on here you know
what what is the how do we
how do we read out the electrical
signals from our brains and find out
what they mean
well it's pretty difficult we could
imagine doing the same thing with a
computer we could imagine tapping into
the electrical signals in a computer
back in the day and i haven't tried this
recently if you've got an old analog
radio
and you held it up near your computer
you should be able to
uh hear a little bit like the eegs from
our brains sort of the collective effect
of all of the various electrical things
that are going on in your computer
transmitted as electromagnetic radiation
and picked up by radio i haven't tried
them a long time
back when i first used computers like 45
years ago
that was a really common thing to do you
could really tell what was going on in
your computer by whether it made all
these
weird squawking sounds and so on when
you hold up a radio to it
don't know whether that still works um
depends on the shielding and these
computers and among other things
in any case the um the thing that
uh uh so
individual nerve cells you see all these
electrical signals going back and forth
what does it all mean well it's
complicated and uh
it's not easy to decode what it means
and between different people
for sure the details of of what
different nerve cells there are
and exactly what signals they produce
will be completely different
so now a question is okay are these
electrical signals between nerve cells
are they the whole story of the way
information is processed in our brains
or other other kinds of things going on
so one big feature
of our brains is is memory um
and the question is in in this network
of nerve cells
how do we how do we have memory and and
kind of the i think the
the the the sort of the main theory
which seems to be seems to be
uh uh up uh correct
is that at the synapses between nerve
cells there are
uh little channels that are things like
calcium channels and so on
almost little tiny rocks that are
developed by
um uh by the presence of um
the um but by when a memory is formed
what's happening is that you're changing
the amount
of uh uh the way that different nerve
cells interact so
it's as if you're changing the the kind
of the um
uh how much effect one nerve cell will
have on another
that at the lowest level uh maybe there
are
um on the order of um maybe um a hundred
trillion
um uh different uh synapses in the brain
different different
sort of places where you can store this
information about how much effect should
one nerve cell have on another
and that those hundred trillion places
where you can store that
those are presumably what stores all of
our memories
and what seems to happen is that at
first
when a sort of memory is first formed
it's formed in a very fragile way with
particular molecules
in the synapse and then over the course
of time over the course of
i think 15 minutes maybe maybe and then
there's another process
takes hours or a day you get sort of a
long-term memory that's formed
that at some level i is is like these
little tiny tiny channels
that will either let through
neurotransmitter or not
and and so on um between these between
these nerve cells
um and so so that's so sort of one
theory for how brains work is it's just
the electrical activity of the nerve
cells
it's just these memories stored in
synapses and so on
but it's never been clear whether that's
the whole story whether there's
other kinds of effects other kinds of
features of nerve cells beyond that sort
of overall electrical activity
that are important in the way that
brains work now we're getting a little
bit of circumstantial evidence
that sort of the the uh it's just the
electrical activity of nerve cells and
it's just whether a nerve cell is firing
or not
and it's just the effect of one nerve
cell another that that's the whole story
from artificial neural nets artificial
neural nets
are just uh representations in a
computer
of things where you have essentially an
artificial neuron
and it has lots of effects from other
neurons and they are just
numbers and there's a certain weight for
every effect from every other neuron
and when the in a first approximation
when the amount
of of stuff coming from other neurons
exceeds some threshold
then a particular neuron will fire and
it will send its data
to other neurons that's implemented just
typically in software or now a little
bit in hardware
um in in neural networks artificial
neural networks used for deep learning
and so on
the details of the way that works are a
little different
from the way things work or appear to
work in actual brains
there are ways that one can train an
artificial neural network
by giving it a whole bunch of samples
and by back propagating
kind of the effect of errors back into
the kind of the way that one programs
things and so on it's a
it's a kind of mathematical process
based on calculus
that doesn't seem to be quite the same
as the way that brains do it or hasn't
seem to be quite the same
but what's become somewhat clear in
recent
years is that the things one can achieve
with artificial neural networks the ways
one
can let's say recognize objects or do
various kinds of tasks
are pretty similar to what brains manage
to do
and it seems like one has managed to
capture with artificial neural nets the
core
characteristics of lots of things that
brains do
so that's kind of a bit of evidence
circumstantial evidence that we really
did
nail by thinking about just neurons and
electrical
connections between neurons that's kind
of the whole story of what's happening
in brains
now there are some other theories that
have been floating around about other
things that could be going on in brains
for example one theory is oh we're not
just storing memories
in these things like these channels and
the synapses
we actually have molecules like even dna
molecules
that are part of storing memories in
brains that's one possible theory
another theory is that these things
called microtubules which exist on many
cells
which are little uh little uh
protuberances out of the in the boundary
of the cell
that can have very complicated behavior
so they're almost like little hairs
on the surface of the cell very tiny
made of made of um
a small number of molecules um that and
and you can have these
whole collective effects where you have
this sort of wave of stuff going around
microtubules now microtubules can be
important in uh
for example when organisms grow there
are places where microtubules are almost
like
a sort of little tiny arms that reach
out and grab
other cells and move the cells into
position and do all kinds of things
microtubules are sort of powerful ideas
in biology
and it's been thought possible that they
might have something to do with the
operation of the brain
i don't think it's all that likely and i
think it's becoming less likely as we
see
the extent to which artificial neural
networks succeed in doing rather
brain-like
things another thing that's been
uh sort of a possibility is that the
brain makes
strong use of quantum mechanics in in
ordinary mechanics
one is thinking you know there are
always definite things that a system
does in quantum mechanics
kind of the idea is there's a a whole
collection of possible histories
which all simultaneously happen and we
just get to find
the chance that one thing happened
rather than another it's kind of this
thing where
where there's a a sort of an automatic
parallelism that's going on that leads
to ideas like quantum computers and so
on
i'm a little bit skeptical about those
for all sorts of reasons um
there's sort of ideas that this quantum
mechanics might be important in the
brain
i kind of doubt it um i suspect that
that's not the case that really this
model of
neurons that basically fire or don't
fire have effects from other neurons
it's probably more or less right
and by the way one of the things that
always helps in terms of making models
for things
that compute is that in a sense all
computers
at some level are equivalent in the
sense that you can program one computer
to do whatever you can program any other
computer to do
so even if our brains are made in one
particular way
in principle our brains are programmable
to operate in some other way now
now for example with our brains if we
say let's do the kinds of things that
computers that sit on our desks do very
well
let's do them with our brain some of
those things are pretty hard for us to
do with our brains
in practice although they are possible
for us to do with our brains
whether it's working out some
complicated math thing that
uh you know in my in my uh in distant
past i spent
lots of lots of effort um making it so
we didn't have to do those things with
our human brains anymore
we could just get computers to do them
because computers tend to be better at
doing those
but still in principle we can do them
with our brains
let's see all right we got a lot of
questions here
um
so
gosh there's a question from jackbound
it's been argued that the majority of
published research findings in science
are false
they ask since i've obviously read lots
of research papers
what's been my experience are there
fields where academic research is
generally of higher quality
that's an interesting question so
you know there are i don't know how many
papers published a year now maybe a
million
um and they are
written by people with differing um
uh amounts of experience etc etc etc
and also with if you're a professional
scientist professor whatever it's kind
of like you should write
x number of papers per year or you're
not doing your
job now that x varies from field to
field like i think
in mathematics it's quite low in
something like biomedical science it's
quite high
in terms of number of papers you should
publish they're also very different
conventions in terms of are there papers
that are just written by one person or
their paper's always written by a team
of five
or a team of a hundred when people put
their names on the papers did they do a
lot of did everybody who wrote
put their name on the paper do a lot of
work did uh did some of the people do
much less work it's
it varies from field to field there are
different conventions about how this
works
the question is uh you know how do you
like get the right answer
in these papers because science is hard
and um
sometimes um uh i think that the um
uh the system that has developed over
the last
uh well it's basically scientific papers
have
sort of existed as a kind of a thing
since about the
the late 1600s was when the first
scientific journals came into existence
it's kind of fun to read some of the
early ones because they're very much
more like modern blog posts they're very
much more informal they're very much
more
things like well i went up to the top of
this mountain and i tried to see this
green flash that happened
but um uh it was cloudy that day so i
didn't get to see it
uh rather than modern scientific paper
which is much more formal
that the kind of thing i just mentioned
is more what you would see in something
like a blog post
today i think it really helps
communication to have some of that
informal stuff because it explains to
you
things like why did the people do this
what
you know what problems did they run into
whereas often in modern scientific
papers all that people do is to say this
is what we did
and if something went wrong it's like
well you don't publish that in the paper
um it's uh and that's that's one of the
issues is that tends to be the case that
you know if you try and write a paper
that says i tried this experiment and it
didn't work
well people say well you can't publish
that paper you're not you don't have
anything to say
well in some sense you really do have
something to say because the next people
come along and wonder
well is that experiment worth doing what
would happen if i did that experiment
they would uh if your paper was
published and they could find it
they'd be like oh okay that person tried
it and it didn't work
now by the way this person x tried it
and it didn't work
story can get complicated because
sometimes people will try and do an
experiment
it doesn't work uh well it didn't work
because of some detail
that people didn't really quite
understand they didn't know it was
important that they
you know uh let the mouse chill out for
for uh an hour before they ran it
through a maze or that they
didn't um that they um uh
didn't um uh put something in you know
that something was supposed to be in
water rather than not being in water
whatever else lots of details they might
not have thought of
and so when somebody says oh it didn't
work somebody tried and didn't work
you have to know a lot more to be sure
that it really didn't work so to speak
well now there's a you know when you
look at scientific papers
there are um it's it's
one of the things which i always think
is a sort of a curse
in in in experimental science
particularly
is when you do an experiment
and you it's not really clear whether
there's an effect
and you have to use statistics to tell
you whether there's an effect so
so in modern times with automated data
taking
it's really common to say i'm going to
measure something and i'm going to get a
million measurements
by the time you have a million
measurements usually
something is either obviously happening
or obviously not happening
and if you draw a plot of your
measurements you'll either see that bump
somewhere or you'll see this
segregation of points or whatever and
it'll be pretty obvious
but let's say that you only had
200 points you only had 100 points and
you
plot them and they all look kind of
random and it's like well is there an
effect or is there not an effect well
you have to start saying
where there's slightly more points to
the left of this line or to the right of
this line
is the number of points more because
when you throw down the points randomly
they'll always by chance be some
imbalance between the number of points
on the left and the right for example
is the imbalance that we have more than
we would expect just by random chance or
less than we would expect just by random
chance
and that quickly turns into a whole
elaborate kind of mathematical theory of
statistics
most of that mathematical theory was
actually developed in the 1930s
um long before people really had the
good ability
to do sort of visual large-scale data
taking visualizations by computer
things like that it was a it was a sort
of a mathematical technology
created to kind of tease out an effect
when you didn't have very many data
points and when it was really hard to do
it
much of it was developed for
agricultural uh
investigations where people would say we
have this crop
we put down this fertilizer in this part
of the field
we put down another fertilizer in the
other part of the field which you know
how much
does this fertilizer really have a
positive effect or not
so that led to things called p-values
for example
those are a little bit more modern than
that but they they arose from
that kind of uh investigation um which
is kind of gives you
uh estimates of sort of the probability
that what you would see
is not what you would think you what you
would see just by pure chance the
probability that they're sort of really
in effect
so now if you look at for example in
medical papers
they'll always be quoting p values and
they'll always say
we have a certain uh we have certain
sort of critical p values that we've
achieved which are
sort of the test for whether the effect
was real or not
unfortunately to roll in all of that
mathematical statistics from 1930s
you have to make a bunch of assumptions
about the true nature of your data for
example you have to assume
that everything is kind of if you
randomly pick
things that the values you'd get from
randomly picking them fall on a gaussian
bell curve
type shape so you know if you look at
human heights for example
in a pretty good approximation you
collect get a collection of people
the the the probability that somebody
will have a certain height
is roughly uh distributed according to
this gaussian bell curve shape
but other kinds of things are absolutely
not distributed that way but usually the
methods that are used for doing the
statistical analysis
have to assume that everything is
distributed that way
so that's one of many reasons why
they'll tend to get the wrong answers
and so that's a that's a horrible and
challenging thing
that you'll see these things that look
very scientific
and look very kind of oh yes we've got
precise results
we've got a p-value of whatever we've
got uh you know something happening at
this confidence level blah blah blah
blah and it looks very precise but if
you peel it all
out it's it's actually uh
it's actually something that where it's
really hard to know if that's the right
conclusion
if you could see the raw data and plot
it and it's obvious oh all these points
lie on that side of the curve or
whatever then great you know what you're
doing
but there's a tendency to try and wrap
these things in particularly
mathematical statistics
and make it seem like it's very precise
with all kinds of numbers
but in fact it's kind of hiding the fact
that there really isn't enough data to
make a good conclusion and so on
so it's very challenging i think in the
biomedical area particularly challenging
in that regard
i think in in the um in the case of
other fields and more theoretical fields
um the uh well the different kinds of
things that happen
i mean more theoretical fields one of
the things that can happen is
papers can get extremely technical like
you look at this thing and it's like
what on earth are these people talking
about you know
i think i know this field but what are
these people talking about
um sometimes the papers are not very
well well written in terms of exposition
often one of the problems is that they
don't say why they're doing things they
just say
consider this this this and this okay
then this happens
it's like okay you get to i always i'm
looking towards the end of the paper and
it's like
why do we care what's going on it's like
you get to the end of the paper and it's
like oh gosh
they got to the end of the paper and
they still didn't say why we cared
so but but it can be very technical
and and sometimes can be very technical
and just completely wrong
because somebody had you know built this
sort of technical tower and didn't
really understand all the details of it
and it ended up just going off in the
wrong direction i think that the um
uh you know one can imagine a world
in which for example for mathematical
papers one can imagine a world in which
machines could check these papers in
which
there are kind of written out in a
sufficiently formal way that one can
have a machine
say does this follow does this step
forward from this step unfortunately
it's sort of a trade-off because when
you do that you're essentially writing a
piece of code
that is very very low level code that is
perhaps understandable to the computer
but
absolutely incomprehensible to the
humans when you give the big picture of
the big sort of narrative of what's
happening
that's something where humans can get
something out of it and can understand
what's going on
but being able to sort of automatically
check it is not something that you have
now you know in a sense a lot of what
i've tried to do with our computational
language
is to provide a kind of a sufficiently
high level computational way to
represent things
that it's both understandable to humans
and
runnable by computer and checkable by
computer and i think that's kind of as i
see it
unfortunately i've been seeing it this
way for 30 years so it's always very
frustrating when you can see what has to
happen
but you wait 30 years to to make it
actually happen
is increasingly this notion of
computational papers
in which you're writing out things as
pieces of computational language
so that they're things that can be
explicitly run as well as just
read by humans but it's got to be the
case that they're both readable by
humans
and runnable by computer not a big wall
of code
that where you look at it as a human
it's like well i don't know if this is
right or wrong
and another thing that comes up is is
the data
that is the backup for papers often
there's been sort of an idea you know
some government will say we supported
the the work on this paper we paid for
the work on this paper
therefore we want you to make the data
from this paper available to everybody
and people say well they in principle
they do that
but in practice doesn't work out in
practice you go to the
you know the place where you're supposed
to collect the data and you find a word
processing file that has some stuff in
it
you can't tell what's going on et cetera
et cetera et cetera another thing that
we spend a lot of effort on
is to make our computational language
such that you can really make data
computable
so that you can like take your raw data
of all those measurements that you so
carefully made and actually
put it in like our data repository in a
form where
other people can do computations from it
and you can do computations from it
in the future and those are things that
i think will will
can really help in the sort of
reproducibility and
and correctness of things in science um
but uh you know the the the number one
problem i suppose is that you know maybe
there are a million papers published but
i think that
the the fraction that really people
think oh this is really interesting
um is is quite small and a large number
of those papers sadly
will be read by almost nobody now it's
it's a cool achievement and it's
something honestly i sometimes feel like
i write things down because that way
at least i'll be able to find them in
the future even if nobody else ever
reads this thing
at least i'll know i wrote down this
argument or this
of this result somewhere and that's
useful to me
and that's some that's not a bad thing
to be doing um and if other people read
it well
great that's a bonus so to speak
all right let's see oh so many questions
you guys ask just
um uh
oh there's a question here about
um
oh gosh shoot so many questions all
right
it's a question here from lolita is it
possible to slow climate change by
creating like a layer of clouds to lower
the temperature
a bit okay so first thing to say about
about climate change is
the history of our planet has been
one in which the climate gradually
changes things
change uh you know us humans
probably have some of no doubt have some
effect on changing the climate but the
chime
climate's going to change anyway and uh
you know it has done over the course of
recorded history
there have been times when it's been
super cold or winter times when it's
been warmer
even in the 1600s it was you know there
were periods of time when it was
sort of a little ice age and it was
really cold for a while and
you know things change and um
one of the things i think that has uh no
doubt we have an effect on the rate at
which certain things are changing
but things change anyway and one of the
things to realize about modern times
is that it is much more difficult for us
to deal with change today
than it probably was even a few hundred
years ago because
today you know we built up all these
cities we've got real estate values
we've got
all the structure that we built and if
it turns out
that you know cape cod in massachusetts
is washed away by the ocean
or you know florida has uh you know the
the ocean rises and beachfront is no
longer beachfront and so on
that's a big deal for us today maybe 500
years ago people would just say well
you know whatever you know over the next
generation they'll probably move in land
a bit and it's not really a big deal and
we'll
you know we'll pick things up and and
move them um but now
you know we've got a society and a
civilization where we've really
relying a lot on the way things are
right now
and so if we can like change you know if
things are going to change well that's a
problem
but i think one thing to realize is it's
just the nature of
you know a planet so to speak that
things change
now if we say okay we really really
don't want things to change
let's lock it in so nothing changes
whether we're causing the change
whether the change is just happening
naturally um doesn't really make any
difference we could
still say let's try and lock in no
change
now some people might not like it i mean
people might say well i'd prefer it if
it was warmer in the you know
where i live and other people say
whatever you know but
let's assume that we wanted to just lock
it in no change
could we do that could we in a sense do
the kind of
the geoengineering necessary to
make it so that there really isn't any
change well there are a bunch of ideas
for how one might do that
uh it's always very concerning because
one says
let's make a change to our whole planet
well that's
you know it's like well it may benefit
somebody it may not benefit somebody
else it's hard to agree on
et cetera et cetera et cetera but but
still from a pure science point of view
we can say what could we do to change
the climate of our planet
many proposals so there are things that
involve putting
uh layers of aerosol into the upper
atmosphere so one of the biggest issues
is
how much does the sun heat our planet
and the sun might heat our planet more
or less depending on how much
uh heat the sun is putting out so for
example
um one of the things that happened in
1600s was there were very few sunspots
which probably meant that the amounts of
something to do with the layers of
outer uh the layers of turbulence in the
outside of the sun that were different
and the total heat
output from the sun was probably
slightly different and that probably
cooled the earth slightly maybe i'm not
sure that's correct
but that's a theory um and so one thing
is you know maybe there are changes in
the sun
that can change the amount of energy
that's coming from the sun to the earth
are there also slight changes to do with
them and
how long is it 46 000 year cycle i think
to do with the orbital orbit of the
earth to do with the earth ending up
being more
closer or further from the sun by a
small amount those can have an effect as
well
so the that's first thing and we don't
get to
go and you know adjust the sun so
anything we do has to be something we do
more locally
but the the big thing tends to be how
much
uh heat energy comes from the sun and
makes it to the surface of the earth
and so um and then how much of it is
radiated back from the surface of the
earth back into space
um and so that's where it really matters
whether you have you know the so-called
greenhouse gases
which prevent radiation back into space
and so on
uh things like this but but so one way
that you can
adjust the amount of heat energy that's
coming to the surface of the earth
is you just put a thin layer of
something that reflects
uh that reflects the light and heat back
out of the out of the earth away from
the earth
and you put that thin layer in the upper
atmosphere of the earth so that's one
possible way to do it
people talk about also just putting you
know giant mirrors into earth orbit i
don't know how much of an effect that
that has and i don't know how many you
have to have before that's really
significant
people talk about oh there's so many of
these proposals
i mean there's a lot of stuff to do with
reducing the carbon dioxide level in the
atmosphere
you know plants use up carbon dioxide
and produce oxygen and us animals and so
on and our machines and so on
tend to consume oxygen and produce
carbon dioxide
so you know right now i think there are
about two trillion trees on the surface
of the earth
if you put more trees on the surface of
the earth you can eventually
you know ingest more carbon dioxide you
can also have a variety of
more chemical schemes for a machinery
that will just ingest carbon dioxide
from the atmosphere
and do things with it i think one
proposal i saw recently
was uh taking the um uh the mineral
olivine which is a very common mineral
in the earth's surface
and uh when it reacts with seawater
apparently
it uh can ingest lots of
carbon dioxide and so that uh one
proposal was you just scatter olivine on
beaches
all around the earth it happens olivine
happens to be a green mineral so that's
a
that's that's uh that's a kind of gives
you a cool coloring as well
and then the interaction of the olivine
with the
sea water will allow a chemical reaction
in which in which carbon dioxide is kind
of ingested and turned into calcium
carbonate
um i don't know if that uh fully works
and it's always
hard to know with these with these
schemes you have to do a lot of
calculations to work out what effects
they have
another one that was popular for a while
was the idea of seeding a southern ocean
with iron
because one of the things that also can
ingest carbon dioxide
is plankton tiny microorganisms in the
in the ocean
um that uh um sort of do the same kind
of thing that plants do
and um uh ordinary land plants do
um and uh and ingest carbon dioxide but
the question is how do you get
more plankton to exist in the oceans and
i think the basic idea was you feed them
with iron which is one of the nutrients
that they don't have enough of
in the ocean you just go with a ship and
you just you know
spew out lots of iron into i think
particularly the southern ocean i've got
i don't know why the southern ocean is
the right one to do it in
um but that was that was another
possible scheme
there are a whole variety of these kinds
of schemes
and uh you know many of them would
probably work
they're a little bit it's a little bit
concerning
to imagine actually deploying one of
them because you know what one has to do
is calculate
what effect will that have on the earth
you know if one changes it in this or
that way
how much will that change these wind
currents that do this how much will that
change these ocean currents
that do that how much will it increase
the
way that clouds and the tropics dump
rain or whatever else
it's hard to know and the computer
models that one has for working these
things out
are complicated and in fact there are
some sort of fundamental problems
in in kind of being able to make
long-term predictions
for for how systems like climate will
work
the things that i've studied a bunch
phenomenon called computational
irreducibility
that basically tells one that figuring
out just saying oh
i know what's going to happen it's going
to be this there's sort of an inevitable
chain of unintended consequences
that happen when you try and do these
kinds of simulations so it's a
challenging thing
but in terms of the sort of physics of
can you do things
that will for example cool the surface
of the earth the answer is absolutely
and will they have will they be
significant in terms of of um
uh is is it is it sort of possible with
things that could really be done without
costing you know trillions of dollars is
it possible
to um uh to to make changes the answer
is almost certainly yes
and it's probably a lot cheaper to do
that than just to say let's shut down
all industrial production of this or
that
um to achieve the same thing but it is
also it's a it's always a difficult
thing to know
you know what exactly will the
consequences of one of these pieces of
geo engineering be
but it's an interesting area of of um
particularly sort of technology and
science
and inevitably public policy as well
uh
let's see
it's a question from pranjul here asking
how do birds fly and
is it um difficult to
understand and mimic it that's an
interesting question and i'm not sure i
know
uh fully the answer to that question
so back um in the 1800s
people were very interested in could one
make a flying machine
and the most obvious
approach would be mimic a bird you see
birds flying around all over the place
let's just do what birds do
and so there were there's there's um
there's some wonderful
movies of this kind of thing of people
with their flapping
you know flying machines which were just
bird-like
and a lot of a lot of unfortunate things
of people jumping off you know
tall things with with various flapping
contraptions
um to to try and fly like birds and it
didn't work very well
um the the kind of engineering
constraints on a bird are fairly
different from humans birds are rather
light they have
they have very um uh they have very uh
airy bones and they have um which are
they don't have the same kind of dense
bones that we do and so on
they tend to be quite light but what was
realized and
kind of the achievement of the wright
brothers um back
uh you know when they first were flying
planes
one of the big achievements was it
wasn't so much about getting the lift
to keep the plane up in the air the big
thing was
having the plane not become unstable and
sort of tip to one side
and end up in a situation where it
couldn't get the lift to keep it aloft
because you know you can make a glider
where you can say
you've got this or a kite for that
matter where you say i've got this thing
and you can kind of keep it uh you know
you can uh
well for example if you just have a a
sort of a single a single wing
and you just make it and you make it you
you know run it forwards through the air
if the wing is tipped up a bit it will
get lift and it will pull
up the issue is if you want it to if you
want to control it if you want to take
it off
turn it around land it and so on how
does that work
and that's hard and the thing that the
wright brothers figured out
is how to get better control of a thing
that was flying through the air
and they had a whole elaborate scheme
which i don't think is really used it's
um
uh what was it term wing warping and
things where they actually
twist the wings slightly and so on
people found slightly simpler ways to do
the same thing
but the main thing that was achieved
there was being able to control it
so that it was stable and that's the
main issue i think with flapping
devices is controlling them so they're
stable is tough
now by the way you know one of the new
kinds of flying machines that wasn't
common in the past but is very common
today is drones
drones typically have you know let's say
four downward pointing
propellers and that they're held up by
the
by the the air being pushed down by
those propellers
the question is why weren't drones built
years ago
and the answer is well partly it's
because of battery technology and being
able to
to um keep enough uh uh energy in the
drone
to um to have it flying for a while but
more important
was even for a short amount of time you
couldn't maintain stability of the drone
the thing would be would be always oh it
would you know one side would tip
up and then the whole thing would tip
over and so on you have to have a flight
controller
uh a microprocessor in the drone that
can figure out oh
i'm noticing my accelerometer tells me
that one side is going up the other
side's going down okay
change the speed of this rotor this
propeller slightly
and that you know to make the thing
become stable and um
so that was a piece of mathematics
control theory that
let one understand how to produce that
kind of stability
and then a question of how to implement
that using
uh sort of fast enough that you could
actually not have the thing become
unstable on the instability
make it fall out of the sky and so on so
so the
the problem of flight um of of even
things like a drone
with you know four propellers and so on
is is uh it's
a lot of it is the story of how you
could do you control it
now birds have brains and so they in a
sense had it easier
because they had sort of an onboard
flight controller from the get-go so to
speak
and i suspect a lot of what's involved
in bird flight has to do with the way
that control works
of you know oh yeah you're an eagle put
that wing down slightly because
that way you won't fall over just like
when we walk we have a pretty elaborate
system
that allows us to not fall over even
though gosh it seems completely crazy to
be able to walk on two legs
um but yet we have a control system that
prevents us from from falling over using
things like the balance organs in our
ears and and so on
uh and you know using our brain to
decide oh well you actually have to put
a little bit more force on that side to
stop
tipping over in that way etc etc etc so
i think that's a large part of the story
and you know could you make a flapping
device
that would fly these days with more
modern controller technology i suspect
the answer is yes
i don't think it's particularly good way
to do it because i don't think i think
that
with birds because of the way muscles
work it's um it's good to
flap if you are using machinery
it's good to turn like a propeller for
example
which you know in biology we don't have
a lot of examples of places where things
turn like wheels sometimes in in
bacteria they have these flagella
that are actually made if you look at
them an electron microscope or something
you can actually see
they'll typically have this this ring of
um
of of molecules around them that in
which they're basically turning like a
little motor
they're turning that little sort of
tail-like thing but it's pretty rare in
biology to find
wheel-like things out there and so that
happens to be something that's
technologically easy for us to build
it's not so easy for us to build
flapping things and it's not as
as convenient a piece of engineering so
that's why i suspect we haven't seen a
lot of flapping stuff
out there technologically flying i mean
that there's there's a lot of complexity
in
in flight for example for insects the um
i think a lot of insects when they fly
and i'm not going to be able to do this
when they fly as they bring their wings
back
their wings actually touch as they come
up and and i think there's a whole lot
of
elaborate aerodynamics as the wings pull
apart when they're going to
do a downstroke there's a lot of
elaborate stuff that happens there
but but i it's my impression that
there's pretty decent understanding of
the aerodynamics of how birds and even
insects fly
and it just isn't very technologically
sensible to make flapping flying
machines
um at this time
let's see
looking at
oh boy okay
um
well okay there's a question here
um from
martian uh refers to a previous question
what does it mean when a paper is peer
reviewed who are the peers
okay so one of the ideas
in in academic
uh journals and so on is somebody writes
a paper
and then the idea is to get uh
other scientists to read that paper and
say whether they think it's right or not
and at some point in the past
it's actually fairly recent i think
fairly much last 50 years
um the which is recent by some standards
um this notion of anonymous peer review
so you send your paper into a journal
and then the editor of the journal the
person who's in charge of what goes into
the journal
will say okay this paper seems to be
about this and this and this i'm going
to send it
to you know jim and jane and
bob and whoever to um uh
to review it as um and
and we're going to have those reviewers
be um anonymous to the author so
so one of them might say i think this
paper is great another one might say i
think this paper is nonsense
another one might say something else
they write up reports
those get sent back to the original
author of the paper
and uh the idea is that this is sort of
a fair way
to figure out whether that paper is good
or not
in practice this system works horribly
and uh it you know it's a good idea in
principle
it's a super bad idea in practice why
does it work horribly
well one reason i think it works
horribly
is you know one thing is it's like why
would somebody do this anonymous peer
review
what you know what what's in it for the
reviewer you know it's like
well one reason is sometimes if it's a
person who's earlier in their career
it's like well i wanted to read this
paper anyway
i might as well read it and make
comments on it um great
but a lot of times it's like well if i'm
going to review this paper
then you know if the paper is nice to my
work and has a lot of
citations to my work and so on then then
great let me accept this paper so that
my you know it's kind of a natural
selection thing
so that my own work propagates better if
the paper
is against my work then oh i better
reject this paper because i don't want
that out there in the world
now you might say that's not a very you
know that's not good intellectual
integrity to do that
and it's not and sadly that's
the that's a very very common thing that
happens
um and so you know that that's another
that's one phenomenon another phenomenon
is
oh yeah this paper is by my friend so
and so sure i'm sure it's okay
you know stamp on it goes now people
sometimes try and deal with that by
having
by removing the name of the author from
the paper that gets sent out for review
that also doesn't work very well because
papers contain you know people tend to
refer to their own work they'll mention
their own work so it's not too hard to
figure out whose it is
and also in modern times most people
post their papers
as preprints and i should have said
you know most papers that ever get
written these days get posted
on on the web before they are published
and most people who are going to read
these papers read them before their
quotes published
but there's still this kind of whole
system of academic journals
tens of hundreds of thousands of
journals that publish things in
particular areas
in a sense it's a it's a stamp of
approval
that your paper and usually many
journals
it's like you send your paper to one
journal and not other journals it's like
if it's published in
this journal then it can't be published
in any other journal um
not always the case but that that's
usually how it works and in a sense to
be published in journal x is kind of a
stamp of approval
that that the the the kind of the
reviewers and the editor and so on of
that journal thought oh yeah your paper
is good
it's kind of a way of doing selection of
content and so on
um and also at universities it's often
this idea of sort of how many
peer-reviewed papers have you published
that uh is what determines things like
you know do you get that promotion do
you get the pay increase
etc so in any case it's unfortunately
the system is is um uh it's sort of
fraught with difficulties and i have to
say i've not been a believer in it for a
long time
i mean i know when when i used to uh i
get asked to
review papers all the time but i haven't
done it for years um
but uh you know when i used to do it i
always used to say look
if i'm gonna write something about this
at least i want the authors to know
that i put the time into reading their
stuff and writing something about it i'm
going to sign my review
and it's like and a lot of journals were
like you can't do that this is supposed
to be anonymous it's like
why is it anonymous it's anonymous to
protect me so to speak
i don't want to be protected i'm happy
to just you know tell the authors
whatever i'm telling them either you
know look i don't think your paper is
correct why don't you do this instead
or looks great or whatever it is um but
it was sort of interesting to see that
that was a
a thing that really confused people you
know i i tend to think that
that um uh anything that gets done
in terms of the kind of review of of uh
uh you know it's useful to know that
somebody you know
read something and they thought it was
good because that gives you
more of an indication that maybe you
would understand it and i think it was
interesting too
but i think that doing that as a sort of
open process is a much better idea than
this kind of mysterious
you know some magic pier will review
this thing i i have to tell you that i
okay i i don't want to corrupt anybody
here but but
um there's a journal that um that i
started
how long ago is it now 34 years ago
i haven't been involved in it's in its
um uh and what it publishes for years
and years and years but
but i know that the people who've edited
it um one of the problems that they can
have is
if you send papers to senior people in a
field
they'll always have kind of access to
grind they'll say oh no
that person's writing this paper comes
from the rival
group that is blah blah blah and
although the senior people might know
more about the subject
they also have many more kind of
prejudices about what's going on
and so the optimal people to send papers
to if you actually want somebody to read
the thing
are these more junior people who might
know a little bit less
but they don't have as you know there
isn't the same kind of prejudice there
and and you get a more accurate
assessment of of whether
the thing is interesting and has
something good to say
let's see
um
okay there's a question here oh my gosh
you guys are asking
so many questions um
let's see
okay there's a question from um uh
udacio
saying i want to teach science to my
three-year-old
sister what subject should i teach
that's a good challenging one
i think one of the things i notice okay
i have four kids they have different
levels of interest in science
and um uh one of the things i've noticed
is
as soon as they were curious about
something
if there was something interesting tell
them about it great
if they weren't curious kind of it's
yeah it's not so easy to you know you
can explain a bunch of stuff but you
have to
do a really good job selling it um
and uh you know so so sort of the
natural curiosity thing
is always a really good driver but there
are situations in which
you will be somewhere and if you point
something out as
oh look at that thing and then the
person's like kid is like
hmm i wonder why that happens that way
or i wonder what happens if you do this
or that
um that's a that's a good start i think
also sometimes
the um uh i'm not sure
three years old i'm i'm i'm um um
uh challenging not sure what the right
answer that is i think there are all
kinds of things to do with them
i think one of the things that can
happen is you know
you'll um here's a sort of funny thing
that can happen
cautionary tale right you show some kid
something where the big thing is that
some liquid turns green
let's say was it was transparent it
turns green
but you know and to you that may be very
significant but to the
to the kid the fact that you have this
thing and it's it's glassware it's got
all kinds of boiling stuff in it and so
on
that's the thing that's significant to
them the fact that oh there's this thing
that turned green it's like
i didn't even notice that so sometimes
the thing that
um you know it's sometimes it's kind of
an acquired taste to know what it is
that
you should be noticing so to speak um
and so i think it's
it's a um uh you know you have to pick
things where
you have to be a little bit careful to
pick things where it's really a very
obvious thing that happened
um i don't know i'm trying to think for
that
age group um
i don't know i always used to claim to
my wife that i couldn't deal with
children under the age of 10.
um and that that set a low expectation
so when our kids were younger than 10
the fact that um i could interact with
them at all was seen as a as a bonus so
to speak
um but uh in any case the um
uh yeah i'm trying to think i'm i'm i'm
um
there are probably some things i mean
the other thing is sometimes
there are things where you'll learn
something at one age
you'll understand it in a certain way
but it doesn't really do you much good
because it doesn't really connect to how
you learn it later on
and it doesn't really like for example
you can teach kids to read when they're
really really young
um and uh but it doesn't really seem to
stick
and it doesn't and they end up having to
re-learn how to read a bit later usually
um and it's not clear it really had an
advantage to do that
um i think that um
you know i think one of the things that
can happen is
you know what is it that stimulates sort
of natural curiosity i don't really know
i
i my sort of pseudo meta theory is that
everybody is born with a with a
considerable degree of natural curiosity
and the only thing that really happens
is that people
get sort of talked out of it so to speak
um and that so long as
people are not talked out of it all is
good and the curiosity remains
and i think sometimes even if you
explain things too much sometimes that
can be a problem because it's like
oh everything that happens has an
explanation and there's a
you know it it's it's complicated and i
and as i say i'm i'm um
i don't know for that age group
um
let's see
um it's a comment here today's
aerodynamics are actually based on bird
physics
not so sure about that we don't have a
lot of feathered birds
um and i know some of the some of the
details of what's done on on airplane
wings
is is some i don't know
okay
let's see
aha there's a comment here from eudacio
in brazil we do not learn that the
wright brothers invented the airplane
but instead a person named carlos
dramant brazilian
interesting yeah i mean you know it is a
it is a curious thing i i know
uh television is one thing where
depending on what country you're in
you will learn a different inventor for
television um
and uh sometimes you know there is
the history of inventions can be very
complicated it's like somebody had the
idea but they didn't quite make it work
oh somebody had this thing and it was a
sort of a plane and it went for 100 feet
but then somebody else had a thing that
really flew around the paris air show
and did a you know did something very
impressive and it's like well
where was it really invented uh you know
there's often a big
there's often a big issue with sort of
where was the original idea
who actually made it work sometimes even
the person who made it work
didn't um you know didn't take it the
distance it could have got
and they they really didn't i mean like
you know i think a famous example
heinrich hurts right the discoverer of
radio
made the um uh was 1880 something i
think
um james clerk maxwell
had worked out the mathematical
equations for electromagnetism
and he worked out this fact that there
should be electromagnetic waves
which are uh things with oscillating
electricity and magnetism and
electromagnetic waves
are what
our radio as well as light as well as
x-rays as well as other kinds of things
but people didn't know that radio uh
was possible and this chap heinrich
hertz managed to build a little device
that produced a um sort of a generated a
spark somewhere and picked up the effect
of that
somewhere else and uh therefore
generated you know proved that
uh james clerk maxwell's theory of
electromagnetic waves was correct
and i think he famously somebody asked
him uh you know
is there any use for this idea of um
of of radio of electromagnetic you know
of transmitting electromagnetic waves he
said well
it shows that james clark maxwell's sort
of footnote in his book wasn't quite a
footnote but it was a
you know section his book about drugs
magnet waves was correct
uh this is as far as it goes uh of
course
in reality people like marconi and so on
realized well actually radio has a lot
of implications and lots of things you
can do with radio
and there started the giant set of uses
of radio i mean it was
it didn't help that people imagined that
radio always just went in straight lines
and so it's a big surprise when radio
was found to bounce off layers in the
earth's ionosphere
which allowed one to have radio
transmissions where you could start from
europe
and have a radio transmission that could
be picked up
in in in america and that was something
which made that a lot more useful than
people had imagined it would be
um
let's see
you know okay there's one comment here
from symbio regarding climate change
if all the glaciers melt how will
coastal cities keep the water back
you know it's interesting i i don't know
the full details but you know there's
some countries in the world like
netherlands for example which are
fundamentally below sea level
and have had to have dikes for centuries
and i remember many many years ago
visiting um a group in the netherlands
and they were explaining to me
that uh they were a group that worked on
soil mechanics
which is important if you think about
dikes and they were explaining that
there was a
they were working on the 400 year plan
for
the way that the dykes and the
netherlands would operate and i was just
impressed because
nobody has a 400 year plan for things
people might have you know
if you're very lucky a few year plan but
a 400 year plan that's really an
impressive thing
i mean i i think that the the the
problem of actually building
uh things like dikes is not particularly
hard i mean it's not it's a it's a well
understood thing that's been known
you know since antiquity sort of how to
do that uh
you know for your your you know your
beachfront property or whatever that
that can be um
uh um you know that's that's that's an
issue but in terms of the just the
mechanics
of how to direct oceans to you know you
know how to do
um uh how to keep the oceans out
i think the netherlands um have as an
example of a place which has solved that
problem for a long period of time
that's a question here sort of uh a uh a
personal
question and i i do think i have to go
in a moment here um
uh from drugger riff asking how many
hours of sleep do i get um and
uh the answer is very boring i
i aim to get the you know your average
you know adult eight hours of sleep i
think of course i measure all these
things so i know how much sleep i
actually get and it's usually just under
seven hours
um and uh um
i think uh um the um
um uh uh
it's my theory about these things is is
uh any time that i
you know people have different ways of
working and and i've sort of
uh slowly tried to uh do the best i can
for myself
but um uh you know the theory
of let me stay up all night to work
really hard on this thing
it'll get it done quicker than if i
sleep
and um uh you know if i push myself to
the maximum
and don't sleep and so on then it'll be
down quicker that has not been my
experience because my experiences
by the time i'm sufficiently tired i am
uh
i i find it hard to you know sort of
figure out what to do correctly and so
on and it's always been a better
optimization for me
you know try to get enough sleep and
then i'll be
awake and capable of figuring stuff out
um and that's some uh you know that
tends to be a better calculation
you know i i i suppose that it's a it's
a terrible admission that
um uh the nature of my life is such that
i very
rarely absolutely definitively have to
get up
by a certain time um and so i i tend to
have
the um uh i have you know i
i almost never end up needing to use an
alarm clock and all those kinds of
things
um and uh that probably helps my
uh you know i'm sure for lots of kids
who are like
well if they're if they're going to
school at some early time of day or even
going in some sense of going whatever
that means today
um that uh that tends to be um um
uh you know that that can that can um
affect uh you know you're kind of forced
to be up at a certain time
and um uh that that probably does all
kinds of terrible things to one's
ability to
uh to sort of sleep long and prosper so
to speak
um the uh okay i think we need to um
uh wrap up here and actually i am about
to do
a another live stream about a completely
different topic we are
we are in the um uh we are just
finishing a new version
of our wolfram language uh software
system
it's version 12.2 um and uh
so that means we're kind of trying to
wrap up a bunch of
design reviews for it um and that's what
i
do for living is try and um
lead our efforts to make great
technology and
our company to do that um and so i got
to go do some
day job work but i'm gonna live stream
it because we've been live streaming
a lot of our kind of internal design
reviews i think this one is about
geography
and dates um so uh
um uh the um
so i think i have to um um
uh to sign off here uh for today
and um i uh look forward i think i'll
be uh been trying to do this every week
at same same time
um i'll see you then and for people who
are interested in more technical things
by all means join the live stream that
we
are about to do about uh
geography and dates in making and making
those computable
okay great thanks so much bye for now